[Musique]
une panne d'électricité comme cela on
n'avait pas vu ça depuis 15 ans à 16
heures cet après midi sept cent
cinquante cinq mille foyers étaient
privés de courant surtout en montérégie
sept cent cinquante cinq mille abonnés
ça c'est le quart de la clientèle
d'hydro-québec ça recommence le matin et
ça c'est sans fin de journée les gens de
saint jean se préparent à un long siège
90% de la population n'a pas de courant
et si après 29 ans d'un conflit qui a
fait plus de 3200 morts et trente sept
mille blessés
les protestants et les catholiques
d'irlande du nord se sont donnés
aujourd'hui un accord de paix a dit le
gros acheteurs les américains sont
friands de ce genre de confession
c'est une histoire d'amour une affaire
de séduction l'homme et la caméra l'
enquête du bureau canadien de la
sécurité des transports prend maintenant
toute la place et monopolise toutes les
énergies avec disco et autour du point
d'impact en mer rare unanimité à
l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui et les
108 députés ont voté en faveur du projet
de loi anti tabac du ministre de la
santé jean rochon les venu le temps des
cathédrales
laurent est entré
[Applaudissements]
à voir
bon
[Musique]